señor presidente colegas
este año marca el aniversario 75 de la
guerra antifascista y la fundación de
naciones unidos ayer
las reuniones de alto nivel para
conmemorar este aniversario de la onu se
llevó a cabo la reunión fue una muy
significativa porque reafirmó nuestro
compromiso con los propósitos y los
principios de la carta de naciones
unidas
revisando las lecciones de esta guerra
en contra del fascismo
señor presidente nosotros humanos
estamos luchando contra el kobe 19 o un
virus que ha generado gran daño en el
mundo y que continúa apareciendo y
resurgiendo hemos visto los esfuerzos de
los gobiernos la dedicación de los
trabajadores de la salud las
exploraciones científicas y la
perseverancia del público y la gente de
diferentes países se ha unido con coraje
determinación y compasión y hemos
afrontado de frente este desastre
el virus será derrotado la humanidad va
a ganar esta batalla
siendo así
al enfrentarnos al virus
deberíamos poner a las personas y sus
vidas
primero deberías movilizar los recursos
para una respuesta basada en la ciencia
en ningún caso debería dejarse de lado
en ningún paciente debería quedarse sin
tratamiento la expansión del virus debe
ser contenida
a enfrentar el virus deberíamos mejorar
la solidaridad y hacerlo juntos seguir
el consejo de los científicos a través
de la organización mundial de la salud y
lanzar una respuesta común e
internacional a esta pandemia cualquier
intento de politizar o de estigmatizar
debe ser rechazado
al enfrentar el virus deberíamos adoptar
medidas de control a largo plazo que
deberían reabrir los negocios y las
escuelas de manera ordenada para así
poder mejorar la economía crear empleo y
restaurar el orden social y la vitalidad
que las economías necesitan para
levantarse a través de una cooperación
macroeconómica
no solo para nuestra economía sino para
contribuir a la recuperación global
enfrentando el virus deberíamos mostrar
preocupación y acomodar las necesidades
de los países más necesitados
especialmente los africanos la comunidad
debe tomar medidas robustas
a través de la asistencia y asegurar que
la implementación de la agenda del 2030
para el desarrollo sostenible ayudando a
estas naciones a superar sus
dificultades
y hace unos días
años china
ayudó a liderar esta lucha antifascista
y también la fundación de naciones
unidas hoy con el nuevo sentido de
responsabilidad china está activamente
involucrada en la lucha contra el kobe
19 contribuyendo en su parte para la
seguridad pública global
vamos a continuar
compartiendo nuestras prácticas así como
nuestros diagnósticos y terapias con
otros países y dándole asistencia a los
países necesitados
y también participando de manera activa
en el resurgimiento de las rutas de
transmisión y de trazabilidad del virus
clase
la vacuna china está en fase 3 y cuando
esté lista
esta se creará como un bien público
global lean
y será distribuida china honrará su
compromiso de dar dos mil millones de
dólares de asistencia a lo largo de dos
años para una mayor cooperación
internacional en temas como la
agricultura la reducción de la pobreza
la educación
en el cambio climático los derechos de
la mujer y también apoyando
el desarrollo social económico de las
naciones
señor presidente la historia del
desarrollo de la sociedad humana es una
historia de nuestra lucha contra los
otros nuestros retos y también de
nuestras victorias en este momento
luchamos contra la pandemia de alcoy 19
mientras pasamos al mismo tiempo por
grandes cambios no vistos en un siglo y
personas de todas partes si quieren el
desarrollo de la paz y mayor cooperación
el codis 19 no será la última crisis que
enfrentará la humanidad así que debemos
tomarnos de las manos y estar preparados
para estar para enfrentar retos aún
mayores
primero el code 19 no se recuerde que
estamos viviendo en un mundo global
interconectado
en todos los países
están conectados y compartimos un futuro
común en ningún país puede ganar
de los problemas de los otros
para abajo
van a mantener nuestras políticas
vamos eventualmente
a estar los mismos dificultades que los
demás es por eso que debemos tomar la
visión de una comunidad con un futuro
compartido donde todos estamos juntos
debemos rechazar los intentos de
construir divisiones
y que hará que evita que nos veamos como
miembros de una misma familia
e ir más allá de las disputas
ideológicas y no caer en la trampa de un
choque de civilizaciones
debemos respetar los
el desarrollo de cada país entender que
es un mundo de diverso
y saber qué
esto va a asegurar que la civilización
humana se mantenga siempre diversa y
llena de color
alcoy 19 también nos recuerda que la
globalización económica es una realidad
indiscutible y una tendencia histórica
enterrar la cabeza en la arena como un
avestruz ante esta globalización
económica o tratar de luchar contra ella
va en contra de las tendencias
históricas seamos claros el mundo nunca
va a regresar al aislamiento y nadie
puede acabar con los lazos entre las
naciones
y debemos enfrentar los retos de esta
comunidad global y enfrentar temas
mayores como la brecha de ingresos para
generar un balance entre el gobierno y
los mercados
la distribución de los ingresos y
también del empleo y la tecnología para
asegurar un desarrollo que entregue
beneficios a las personas de todos los
países de todos los sectores y orígenes
de una manera equitativa
debemos perseguir y buscar
estos objetivos mientras construimos una
economía global abierta manteniendo un
régimen multilateral a través de la
organización mundial del comercio
es decir no al proteccionismo y
asegurar el funcionamiento tranquilo de
las cadenas de suministros tercero el
coach nos recuerda que la humanidad debe
lanzar una revolución verde y moverse
rápidamente para un desarrollo
sostenible preservar en la madre tierra
y hacer que ésta sea un mejor lugar para
todos la humanidad no puede ignorar las
advertencias repetidas de la humanidad y
continuar por el mismo camino de extraer
recursos sin invertir en la conservación
y seguir explotando estos recursos sin
restaurar los el acuerdo de parís para
el cambio climático
fue un una base para esa transición
y subraya los pasos mínimos que deben
tomarse para proteger al planeta nuestro
nuestro hogar común y todos debemos
tomar pasos decisivos para cumplir con
este acuerdo china va a aumentar sus
contribuciones adoptando más políticas
vigorosas y medidas
haremos reducir las emisiones de co2
para el 2030 y lograr la neutralidad de
carbono para el 2060 hacemos un llamado
a todos los países para que sigan estos
esfuerzos de cooperación tomar las
oportunidades históricas que presentan
está la revolución tecnológica y
científica a través de la transformación
de las industrias revivir la economía en
una era post kobe y abbas y crear una
fuerza a través del desarrollo
sostenible sin cuarto el cohete 19 nos
recuerda que un sistema global de
gobierno
se necesitan reformas y es una tarea de
la capacidad de los gobiernos pero
también es un test para el sistema de
gobierno global
que debe mantenerse cercano al
multilateralismo y del sistema a través
de la onu como su centro
el gobierno global debe basarse en un
principio de consultas extensivas la
cooperación y los beneficios compartidos
para asegurar que todos los países
disfruten de derechos iguales y siguen
las mismas reglas el sistema de gobierno
global debe adaptarse para las
evoluciones de las dinámicas globales
enfrentarse a los dos retos compartidos
y también a las tendencias del
desarrollo de la paz y la cooperación es
natural que los países tengan
diferencias lo que es importante es
enfrentarlos a través de la consulta y
el diálogo
puede que exista la competencia pero
puede ser positiva
los países que están compitiendo deben
cumplir con las normas internacionales y
los grandes países deben deben
comportarse como grandes países
ofreciendo
y tomando sus responsabilidades y
cumpliendo con las expectativas de la
gente
señor presidente desde el comienzo de
este año hemos
todos los chinos hemos visto nos hemos
visto ante este reto del cobi 19 y a
través del gobierno hemos hecho todos
los esfuerzos para controlar el virus y
restaurar la vida en la economía y
llevarla a su normalidad tenemos
confianza de poder cumplir con estos
objetivos y construyendo una sociedad
moderna
reduciendo la pobreza sobre todo en las
zonas rurales
y cumpliendo rápidamente los objetivos
de erradicación de la pobreza en los
objetivos del 2030 quién es el país de
mayor expansión en el mundo 1 que está
comprometido con un desarrollo lleno de
cooperación y de hacerlo de manera
pacífica
no tenemos ninguna intención de luchar
en una guerra fría con ningún país
vamos a tratar de reducir nuestras
diferencias y resolver las disputas a
través del diálogo y la negociación no
buscaremos
entrar en este tipo de juegos y no lo
que queremos hacer es
crear un nuevo paradigma de desarrollo y
en
con las circulaciones internacionales y
esto va a crear mayor espacio para el
desarrollo de china
y hacer que podamos crecer
reconstruir queremos contribuir al
desarrollo de la paz global y seguiremos
defendiendo la ley internacional y el
orden internacional para apoyar
el rol central de las naciones unidas en
los asuntos internacionales aquí anuncio
los siguientes pasos que serán tomados
con china china va a proveer otros 50
mil millones de dólares
a la respuesta
alcoy 19 también 15 millones de dólares
al fondo de cooperación que entra en su
fase 3 china va a extender en el fondo
de cooperación y confianza
después de que expire en el año 2025
china va a establecer
sí sí sí sí
y un centro de innovación geoespacial
y un centro de investigación de big data
para facilitar la implementación de la
agenda 2030 para el desarrollo
sostenible
señor presidente colegas
cuando la historia ha sido pasado a
nuestra generación y sabemos
hacer la elección correcta una que sea
digna de la confianza del pueblo
tomamos de las manos para mantener los
valores de justicia paz democracia y
libertad que son compartidos por todos
nosotros
y construir un nuevo tipo de relaciones
internacionales
y una comunidad con un futuro compartido
para la humanidad juntos podemos hacer
que el mundo sea un mejor lugar para
todos